ترحيبها باعلان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ان ما شاهده غرب دارفور من فضاعات بحق
المدنيين سيكون محل تحقيقات ومساءلات
فضائيه كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما دلالات ردود الفعل
الدوليه الممدده بما يتعرض له المدنيون في
دارفور وما الرهانات التي تقف وراء
استهداف المدنيين بتلك الوحشيه في دارفور
وغيرها والى اين يقود ذلك المسار القضائي
والغضب الدولي مما يرتكب بحق مدنيين في
دافور
[موسيقى]
الان على السلطات السودانيه بتتعامل بشكل
جد بشكل عقلاني مع المحكمه الجنائي
واللعبه اعتبارها انها ما حدث في غرب
دارفور هي جرائم ينده لها الجبيل الولايات
المتحده قدمت على الدعم لهذه التحقيقات
لاحتمال ان تكون هذه الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
ومشاجر جمعيه امام هنالك الولايات المتحده
تريد السلام وتريد
اليه او نظاما جديدا بحسب ما يطالب به
الشعب المعطيات اختلفت من حيث
التراكميه التي تقوم عليها هذه المساله
بمعنى اننا وراء 300 الف ضحيه في العقد
الاول من القرن الحالي امام اربعه مذكرات
توقيف امام احاله متجدده مثل هذه
الاتهامات
تجعل الكثير من القليو الدوليه تعيد النظر
في التعاطي مع قوات الدعم السريع سواء كان
الاتحاد الاوروبي او الولايات المتحده
الام ريكيه وبعض حتى القوه السياسيه التي
ظلت تتعاطى وتتعامل مع قوات الدعم السريعه
من المهم بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده
ودول اخرى ومنظمات اخرى ان تقف خلف او تقف
داعمه
لهذه التحقيقات
في الفضاء التي ارتكبها مهما كان الطرف
[موسيقى]
تجعل هذه المجموعات المسلحه وهي قوات
الدعم السريع تمارس هذه الانتهاكات وهذه
الجرائم الامر الاساسي يعود الى تركيبه
هذه القوات وطبيعتها هذه القوات تنتمي الى
مجموعات لديها اشكاليه وخلافات تاريخيه مع
بعض المجموعات
الاصيل او السكان الاصليين في المنطقه
دائما في الماضيه يقوم في اطار الصراع على
الارض والموارد انا لا اعتقد ان الموضوع
مرتبط بالعجز عن التوصل الى حل سياسي
ولكنه اعترافهم بان موسى
في جوهر بعض المشاكل
القائمه ليس فقط في دارفور بل في كافه
انحاء السودان
الحركات المسلحه استطاع لهذه المجموعات
السلاح خارج القطر القانونيه المحاكم
والتحقيقات الجنائيه تاتي في المطاف
الاخير ربما من هذه الازمات والنزاعات
الدوليه للاسف نعم
مجلس الامن هو الممر السياسي الالزامي
للعداله الجنائيه الدوليه للاسف الشديد
المحاسبه القانونيه يجب ان تمر بهذا الباب
السياسي وما ادراك ما هي تركيبه مجلس امن
الدولي
صعب جدا ان تستمر هذه الاتهامات دون ان
تقوم قوات الدعم السريعه وتاخده خطوات نحو
الامر في اطار ساعتها سواء كان من خلال
التعاون في اطار تحقيق دوري مستقل كل ما
يحال الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه له
علاقه بالمسؤوليه الفرديه نحن نتحدث عن
قوات الدعم السريع ككيان بل نتحدث عن
افراد اشخاص هم الذين ارتكبوا هذه الفضائع
هنالك فعل تراكمي ممكن له ان يحفز هذا
المسار من التحقيق الجنائي الدولي
وبالتالي ان لا تشبه النتيجه التي سيلول
اليها هذه المره التي تشبه ما افضل اليها
التحقيقات السابقه
ايضا بحجر الموافقه الجيش السوداني ومعلوم
دوامنا ان الجيش السوداني لديه مواقف
مسبقه بعدم رقبته في التسليم البشير وكذلك
عبد الرحيم محمد حسين واحمد هارون
فبالتالي بشكله هو بياثر هذه المواقف
ستشكل عنصر الضخم مهم جدا نحن لازلنا
اليوم امام طلب فتح تحقيق من المدعي
العامه وبالتالي امام توثيق هذه الجرائم
المتعلقه بالجرائم ضد الانسانيه جرائم
الحرب الفظاعات المتعلقه بالمدنيين
والسكان العزه الاطفال الاغتصاب كل ما
ينتهك فعلا اتفاقيات جنيف الاربعه حين
نتحدث عن ادانه اي شخص او اي طرف الادانه
لا تكون لي قوات الدعم السريع
يجب ان يدينوا اشخاصا افرادا يعتبرون انهم
ارتكبوا هذه الفضائع هذه الجرائم اي
المحكمه تدين عند صدور الحكم الاشخاص
الطبيعيين الافراد لكن اذا اذينا مسؤولون
او جنود او يعني قاده فان لذلك رمزي كبرى
فتكون الاذانه نعم هي ادانا شخصيه افراديه
لكن عواقب ومؤده هذا الامر ومفعله تنسحب
على الشخص الاعتبار المعنوي الذي يمثلونه
خلال القيام بهذه المعارف
بالسلم والتعايش المجتمع في دارفور فاذا
كان الاضلاع السوداني هو غير قادر على
تحقيق العداله ففي السودان فينبغي
للاضحايا الانتهاكات والجرائم
يتم نصره هذه الخطوه ايضا ممكن ان تحفز
المسار السياسي
تجاه دارفور باتجاه حل الخلافات من الصعب
جدا التفاوض حول السلام حين لا يكون هناك
فعلا اهتمام بالجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
هناك حاجه الى عمليه بناء سلام شامله حتى
لا نستمر في سماح لقوات دعم السريع او
القوات المسلحه بان تكون هي الاساس والطرف
الرئيسي المعني يجب ان اعطي الكلمه الى
المدنيين لكي ياتوا فعلا بهذا التغيير
الذي تحتاجه السودان